the seven-day free trial of the quranic
app and it exceeded all my expectations
prophecy system you can build a habit
with the quran by seven day free trial
bonuses not credit card details required
at all and you decide for yourself is it
overrated or is it underrated
tell me the arguments
in islam tell me the arguments which
destroyed my position islam i will
debate now the contingency argument
right now let's go
no let's go is this contingent do you
know what it means
yes it is it's contagious
relatively according to the argument yes
it's dependent
yes sure can it be any other way
it could be yes okay good okay so it's
independent it could be any other way
it's contingent okay okay can we let's
do this okay one second do you accept
that there is existence
yes thank you okay there's three kinds
of existence yeah okay there is uh
impossible existence there is possible
existence and there's necessary
existence impossible very dumb way of
putting
one second it's a triangle circle yeah
you're gonna need that water i know
you're getting nervous i know you're
getting nervous you're gonna you're
gonna get just stop just just go with
the point
i'm gonna be your worst nightmare you're
gonna have nightmares about me yeah sure
sure go ahead yeah go ahead come on okay
a triangle circle is an impossible
existence it cannot exist so we have two
things left
um possible existence and necessary
existence yeah that's correct yeah okay
now
do you know what contingent is do you
know the criteria for contingency what
what contingent thing which we just we
just went through that why do you okay
one more time make your arguments make
your arguments don't know what it is
let's go for it again
that's not how you make an argument you
are supposed to make your arguments
i'm asking you do you know what
contingent what's the question you're
supposed to make your argument not ask
me questions yeah i don't know just make
your goddamn argument yeah i don't know
i just told you the answer dude no no no
i just gave you the answer i'm your
teacher i just gave you the answer just
make your argument
i have to ask you i'm teaching a lesson
you have to know i need to see if you're
casual
okay you are so
make your point stop asking questions
okay it cannot be any other way okay it
requires something else for its own
existence okay can you have an infinite
regress of dependent things
uh it's not something we can know you
could say you could argue that uh it is
something that doesn't exist you could
argue that it does exist people are
actually split on that even the guy
himself who talked to me is split on the
definition of infinite and of on actual
infinites and not actually if it is do
you know what that means you probably
don't know what that actually infinite
is in the real world there is potential
infinite but actual infinite doesn't
exist in the real world if i had
influence do you think do you think the
17 year old debater from a few days ago
agrees with you listen listen i don't
know do you think he
get to your point get to the argument
okay so i'm saying to you that you can
can you have uh infinite in the real
world no if i had if there was infinite
amount of apuses may allah protect us
and i slapped two and they and it died
okay how many apostles are there
keep making your arguments come on no
i'm asking questions questions make your
argument that's an argument
you don't answer you don't ask questions
doesn't exist in the real world so
therefore i'm telling you have you never
made an actual argument
okay can there be an infinite um um are
you dumb you are asking me a question
again
make your argument stop asking me
questions
make your argument stop asking questions
could be i don't know no depending no no
dependent no sorry dependent knowledge
i just said no i misspoke i misspoke i
said no okay dependent therefore
therefore you require a necessary being
for order in all those dependent things
to fall back on now what's the condition
for unnecessary being do you know
go ahead you don't know it's not yeah i
don't know
just go ahead and make your argument
say ali i don't know go ahead make your
argument ali
tell me teacher please tell me now let
me tell you if you're a bad student yeah
you guys never talk to a more annoying
person make your goddamn arguments come
on get to the point
fail you failed you're finished
a necessary being is a being that is
independent self-sufficient cannot be
composed by parts or cannot be any other
way according to which principle
according to what standard is that is
that according to what standard is that
the definition of unnecessary the
logical principles
so
logical a logical principle under what
standard uh by what definition is that
the definition of innocence
explain
okay
please
why is that the definition of a
necessary being contingent things is
what
dependent
uh requires something else for its own
existence it's composed by past and can
be any other way so which follows the
unnecessary being has to be the opposite
because okay the necessary being is
opposite of the dependent thing so now
you tell me can we have a c without a c
bed give me the answer
wow okay we need to do abc here no you
can't do you think i don't know the
answer i'm telling you i have been
telling you for 10 minutes now to make
your articles use your brain build your
brain how could you have see just make
your argument then stop talking just
make sure you argue
you're not even engaging you know why
because you know you got slapped up
but you look like you're gonna cry okay
i don't know you're gonna cry are you
done with the arguments therefore are
you done with the argument are you done
with the argument you have yes i'm done
with the argument can you rebuke it okay
okay of course i can create information
based on based on what uh exactly is god
the necessary being explain it to me
based on what is god the necessary being
click click click
once again i said to you we have
dependent things
we require something that's based on
what is god they're necessarily being
answered no no no no no no no i never i
know what once again i didn't go to god
yet i'm trying to move you from atheism
to deism i haven't even gone to that yet
i didn't say that did i say anything
about god i just different about god
yeah okay so you keep clicking your
teacher it's not going to help you yeah
okay you're finished well you're
finished okay
when you're finished
okay what is what is the necessary being
the necessary being could be anything
what is the necessary
argument good so do you accept that
there's a necessary being
depends on what you would define but
what you mean by necessary being okay
necessarily
it could be that existence itself is
disturbing it could be that energy
dependent it's self-sufficient it's not
okay
i'm giving you a response to
your stupid question are you necessarily
being confused
a necessary being could be anything it
could be energy it could be uh
prior prior to the to the big bang a
perfect balance of energy by the way you
probably don't even know okay
it could be a multiverse it could be a
multiverse which exists it could be a
hierarchy of deities that
is combined by a problem a circle that
forms a necessary being what is a
necessary being that you need to define
that in order to explain to me that a
necessary being proves the existence of
god you need to first answer to me why
you think a necessary being must exist
in all worlds and why you think that
fits the criteria of a god that you
believe in but of course you can't do
that because you don't even know what
you're talking about because you can't
even tell me why a necessary being has
this definition you don't even know the
name of the argument which you're
proposing
are you finished
yes because you are finished in a minute
listen
universe multiverse superverse super
mario verse energy menigy denig whatever
you want to call it
they all are infinitely relied on the
necessary
yes no one second let me look all this
in fault listen to me okay i'm listening
to you listen to me yeah okay
just for just to be charitable i'm
having this to show how ignorant you are
i don't even try trouble
anyway i don't want it
i don't know i just call it argument
okay oh
uh
as far as we know not does it have a
will as far as we know we're not no
intelligence
as far as we know we're not no equals
you're finished man my gosh okay okay
okay how does energy
okay give rise to beings like us who
have consciousness who have a will and
who have intelligence sorry i don't know
and that's what allah says in the quran
you can ask them
you know what they will say okay i don't
know
you're such a giant you know what an
atheist is it's like coming outside my
door and saying get out get out get out
and i'm okay are you done are you are
you done
i don't know are you done
are you done so you couldn't are you
done stop being verbose are you done are
you done ignoramus are you done you're
ignoramus
where where in your where in your
argument for your necessary intelligence
where in your argument for a necessary
being is the condition for intelligence
hey stay with me where in your argument
where in your argument where in your
argument is the requirement that this is
a conscious being a plus don't raise
your voice at
i'm happy you are giving me you're
giving me the argument are you going to
let me speak okay
you're making an argument from
contingency and then you appeal to god
with arguments that are completely
outside the argument in order to say
that this is the necessary being so you
are using completely different arguments
to make your point where exactly in your
initial argument was it a requirement
for a necessary being to be conscious to
have a person to be a a thing that moves
to have an intellect where exactly was
that
and how exactly can you prove
that that is necessary in order to bring
life into existence do you have research
papers for that go ahead prove it to me
come on
i know you are a stupid child go ahead
engage with the argument instead of
talking nonsense come on
okay go ahead
brother go ahead
come on okay
okay okay go ahead so the question you
asked was did you make notes did i no no
i don't know it's for you
for you
answer the question
the f the f i want to give you that's
the only note i have answer the question
come on answer the question yeah okay um
what was the question ask again
ask again
where in
secondly secondly can you prove or can
you present proper evidence that a
person or a conscious being is required
for life or for consciousness to come
into existence okay good firstly go
ahead look i firstly never said that
that is a personal being i'm telling you
i haven't even moved there yet do you
accept a necessary being if you say yes
from there then i can prove to you why
that is a personal god who has
consciousness and has a will and erada i
haven't even gone there yet i'm saying
do you accept a necessary being exists
i just talked to you about how it could
be energy and you ask me questions about
energy
about the about qualities of energy no
no no so you know why the answer is my
question let me tell you why you gave
the issue with energy yeah okay okay
i have to i have to meet you for a
second you have no idea what you're
talking about you have no idea what
you're talking about me don't worry i've
got it all don't worry about that okay
okay you have no idea what you're
talking about i just i just brought up
energy
you as a response said energy doesn't
have a purse a personality what did you
say to me and then you say i never said
okay
you said to me how can this personal
being you're such an
i said to you this energy of
consciousness no does it ever will no
does it have intelligence no therefore
it cannot give rise to something like us
who has intelligence who has
consciousness okay because if it doesn't
let me finish if it doesn't have that
innate properties that uh you let me
finish every time you know what you're
doing but i've been finished let me
finish my point i listen to you let me
finish my point okay don't get angry
it's not my fault you're ignorance don't
blame me don't get angry at me yeah we
completely see that right now
we totally see that right now so let me
finish so i'm saying this if you're
telling me energy is a possibility
energy has no consciousness he has no
will and he has no intelligence so
therefore when i'm talking about a
necessary being it requires for him to
have there has to be he has to be the
all-knowing he has to have some kind of
an existence he has to exist but not the
way we exist okay and he has to have
iran and will to give rise to us
okay so you just said
you just said that you never made such a
condition you just said that you never
have such never made such a condition
which is why i brought up energy as a
possible necessary existence upon which
you said it can't be energy because
energy doesn't have a consciousness
doesn't have intellect and doesn't have
a will
so it is part of your argument and you
used it in order to refute me that
energy cannot be the necessary being
because it doesn't have a personality it
doesn't have a will it doesn't have a
consciousness
and then you appeal to god because god
has a consciousness has a personality as
a being and your reasoning for that is
that
something without a personality without
consciousness cannot bring consciousness
into existence you are a complete idiot
you are a complete idiot where was that
requirement in your argument for a
necessary peak you are such a [ __ ]
thank you thank you okay perfect
presentation yeah everybody knows he
said you are so brilliant thank you so
enjoy this right that's right
where'd you get you no problem so let me
get this right sure go ahead
okay then you came and asked me i
hypothesized with it one second no no
you you first tried to escape it yeah
you know that hypothetically but
okay people are watching okay
people are watching yeah now we talked
about necessary being i gave you the
conditions for necessary being and then
you said to me how is he personal how
does he mean he has consciousness i and
then you mentioned energy
i said to you
if you believe energy that has no
consciousness no will
no intelligence that can give rise to us
so something that doesn't have the
innate properties that we have yeah and
and that can give rise to us but
a
personal being a necessary being who is
independent self-sufficient not composed
of parts cannot be any other way him
having consciousness and a will and a um
intelligence knowledge
impossible you are a [ __ ] you are the
stupidest guy i've met in my life
okay do you have psychological issues
did you define
early earlier you defined your channel
and you're getting destroyed
i'm having mercy on you
how could you go live is that me
uploading a video where somebody knocked
me
earlier when you defined a necessary
being did you define this necessary
being as a being that must have a
consciousness
no i didn't that's why you did not
okay okay number one number one that is
bad
but then you try to refuse
but then you try to refute uh the energy
point by saying it can't it can't be
energy because it doesn't have a will
okay fine although that is completely
stupid it has nothing to do with the
argument i accept that as a proposition
and then ask you can you show me can you
demonstrate to me that a will a person a
personality is required in order to
bring beings or conscious beings into
existence can you demonstrate that to me
then you say no no no no let's get back
to the argument i'm asking a simple
question can you demonstrate that to me
can you demonstrate to me that you must
have a conscious personal being in order
to bring life into existence in order
for life to exist how can you do that
based on what evidence you've asked me
listen to me carefully because genuinely
bro yo i didn't want to call you back
stop with the insults just just give me
the answer apus i am i am i'm just
saying you're looking stupid listen to
what i'm saying carefully you said we
see it right
right everyone is laughing at you listen
you said why can't that not be energy
okay
i want to give you an example is there
an empty glass couple
yeah i'm asking a simple question okay
you said to me it can be energy okay
if it does not if this does not have the
properties
the properties to make a strawberry
milkshake yeah
to say to say if it doesn't have those
elements it cannot give rise to it
it doesn't have it innately you are
telling me do you know what energy is no
let me finish
how do you think the big bang is
explained how do you think the existence
of the first thing is explained
listen to me listen listen listen what
do you think do you think the big bang
comes out of nothing listen to me i'm
saying to you you said to me it can be
energy look even though it's come back
refuted you yeah you guys had a little
debate even he refuted you listen to me
carefully you said it can be energy okay
i said to you does energy have
consciousness
you said no does it have a will you said
no doesn't have intelligence you said no
first of all i said as far as we as far
as we know i know you're cutting because
you're hurt let me finish yeah energy
that doesn't have these properties uh
characteristics we have gave rise to us
meaning it doesn't have innately but
spontaneously we have consciousness and
intelligence
once again it develops but you are the
same guy that says a necessary being
cannot be
um have existence consciousness have a
will and be happy when did i say that
one second
when did i say that you did because
you're saying how does that uh how did
it give rise to us how does that make
sense that's what you see are you dumb
is it
because i'm asking because i'm asking
you how do you know this is god that
that means i say it cannot be a
conscious being are you completely
stupid when did i say that are you a
dumb man painting painting i need to
demonstrate
with abc when did i ever say that can
you can you show me where i said that
can you tell me how you how you came to
that conclusion okay guys
you just
made a
let me finish when did i say when did i
say it can't be a personal being
okay that's what you said
no i didn't
okay clarify
i asked you
how you can demonstrate that it is your
god that's all i said i i haven't even
caught when did i say to you that is
allah when did i even mention god to you
i said to you is there a necessary being
you said to me it can be energy it can
be this and they are all negate what
because i said it cannot be any other
way it cannot be composed of parts
energy is composed of parts it's
dependent it's not independent yeah
and then you brought forth to me a
requirement that it must be personal
which is a requirement that you made up
of this
i listen to you listen to me i'm
teaching you here just be humble and say
ali i don't know the contingency
argument i'm learning
i have actually read books about this
and taken classes did you go to
university
did you go did you go to university bob
jake you messaged jake and said did you
did you take your university class in
psychology
engaging with the argument you you were
going to jake and saying jake you know
i'm sorry i didn't engage with the
argument there now i'm saying to you the
following
let me speak let me make my case stop
stop interrupting me yeah i have
actually read books about about about
this stuff okay you know yeah i'm
getting smashed i'm getting what your
fans are doing
yeah that's what you're
they are laughing at you right now look
into my look into my live chat it's full
with laughter here right now yes yes yes
it's filled with laughter should i share
my screen no problem nope that's right
that's fine let me ask a simple question
okay
you said to me i never mentioned god i
never mentioned allah i didn't mention
none of that i'm saying necessary being
when did i ever mention allah when there
ever mentioned god i never i said yeah
the point is i said if even if there was
a necessary being
this necessary can be energy
and i said no ah
because it can be any other way it's
composed of parts it's dependent it
requires something else for its own
existence so is that part of the
argument for a necessary being it's not
no you're not understanding i'm telling
you
i'm i'm understanding very clearly is
that part is that part of the argument
right now
it's not hurt your butt hurt sure let me
ask you a simple question since you are
so confident
can i speak can i speak now can i speak
excuse me excuse me you cut me out let
me let me i let you speak for the most
of the time can i speak now i didn't
even finish my points just okay go ahead
go ahead finish finish come on i never
mentioned allah or god i mentioned
necessary being i said do we accept as
necessary
and then i said to you the conditions
for that you said to me energy
multiverse and i said no it cannot be
and i gave him my examples then you came
and said how is that allah how is that
god i didn't even mention it now you if
you accept necessary being then say to
me ali okay necessary
how do you how can you prove that is
allah then i will say okay
are you done oh yes that's all you
apparently you're stupid enough to
remember that i very clearly said
assuming that it is a necessary being
how would you conclude that this is
allah assume so i i i actually did
exactly what you now tell me i should
have done
and then you come back with such a
response i mean you are such a [ __ ]
it's unbelievable but since we are since
you are so confident about this and
since people are uh seeing what an idiot
you are uh concerning theological
discussions i mean go watch some debates
do some things please but but since you
are
so confident let me ask you a few
questions ayodawa since you want to be
an educator and a teacher on these
complex topics
where you don't even understand the
terms that you're talking about
uh first question and second question
first question is how many books have
you read about arguments for theism or
atheism second question uh did you take
any university class which includes
philosophy
go ahead
it's got nothing to do with the
discussion please go please go ahead and
answer the question
you asked a lot of things you ask a lot
of things that have nothing to do with
our discussion i'm just asking something
with it because you can't even answer
you know what's bad okay how many books
have you read
i just answered my question come on okay
okay okay no problem i've read argument
said no books and uh i went to no
university argument say okay how many
have you done okay how many of you
that's not that's not for argument it's
the reality it's the reality
it's the reality okay okay okay reality
how many have you done
i have read quite
many books on theology and philosophy i
have taken certain uh online
certificates online courses in official
courses and i also took uh
undergraduate
courses in two fields of philosophy okay
and you want to study and talk about how
you are might you cannot deal without
having done anything let me get this
right i'm somebody argumentative i've
read no books i have no university
degrees i'm using arguments
i'm going to give it to apus he's got
he's made he's read many books he's
teachers and he's getting smashed by
someone like me
i'm writing one right now i'm reading
one right now that's why someone robin
the poet have been arguing for atheists
exactly an introduction to the
philosophy of religion
have you ever heard of something like
this you're reading books i have an
argument
buy something like this
buy something like this and then try to
run away from me so now tell me will you
accept the necessary being now after you
got refuted
we are already done with this topic you
have demonstrated what a complete idiot
you are about this topic
we're done with this people are laughing
at your ignorance
no we haven't finished
you know what you know what you should
do
you should take this section you should
take this section and publish it and say
and say
ignorant atheist destroyed by
knowledgeable mostly published section
please it will be amazing look it's
going to be great
people are going to be correct no
problem
with that it's going to be great
publish it say say ex-muslim atheist
destroyed on god
educated by muslim okay somebody has
read books and apparently has teachers
yeah he's running away from a debate
again do you accept the necessary
we already talked about that we already
talked about it we're done with that
let's go let's come to let's come to my
questions
we're already done with that let's come
to my questions come on
questions let's come to my questions
come on depends on depends on how you
define this survey
let's come to my questions
again where where does the sun go where
does the sun go at night
where does the sun go at night nearly
two hours
muhammad says in the sahih is that the
sun goes somewhere at night where does
it go you're finished bob you are
finished i cannot believe it you've left
the debate
i've read so many books and i have
teachers degrees ali you have none and
i'm running away from debate you coward
you're right you know what
sit down with muhammad
sit down with muhammad and review this
conversation and let him clap
you're running away from an argument
with heaven you carried you
that's what i said okay we're done with
this we're done with this
wait okay
we're done with this we are done with
this we are done with this we are not
having a debate
we are not having a debate
we are not having a debate now i said to
you i will debate you on this topic stop
trying nonsense bob just don't trust me
we're not having a debate
everyone you're not having a debate
people are messaging me they're watching
they're laughing ahead of you oh really
yeah i believe you're totally excited
you said possible is
is
it
possible
so therefore you accept that there's a
necessary being okay good now that means
that's the criteria for us that there is
a creator why because if you accept a
necessary being you need to acknowledge
that he has to have a will possibly
with this nobody is interested in this
conversation come on the necessary being
has to have intelligence right yes or no
no no why not
because it's not part of a definition of
unnecessary being very simple
excuse me
it's not part of the definition of a
necessary being so we're making it we're
making it personal now okay is there
depending on depending on what is there
intelligent is there knowledge in the
universe
uh sure it is yeah okay
how does
a necessary being give rise to the
dependent things contingent things but
has no knowledge how is something that
we uh philosophize and research and
learn and further find out how does it
come into existence according to you do
you have research papers on this what an
answer oh my gosh you have research
papers on this can you give me some
evidence
you might as well say i like banana
orange and milkshake
is that you don't know what a research
paper is right answer is that i'm asking
you
it's a scientific answer actually very
simple to be honest
i'm asking you yet how does this
what is a research paper i have never
heard of such a thing there is knowledge
is a research paper a banana can you eat
it
how does it intelligent look there's
knowledge in the universe it's
intelligence yeah how does the necessity
of being not have knowledge i don't know
i don't know
how does it how does it again again i
don't know what that talks about in the
quran i don't know
i don't know i don't know
how does it show to me show it to me how
does it okay how does it what does it
come into existence show it to me give
me research
give me give me research give me
evidence can you see your consciousness
dude answer my question show it to me
how do you prove your argument
consciousness come on i believe you have
no brain but show me your questions i
can actually show you my consciousness
in terms of hooking things to my brain
showing you activity brain activity when
i'm thinking when i'm dreaming excuse me
yes yes when when two people dream about
similar things they actually have brain
activity that is very similar to each
other
have you have you studied
neuroscientific uh research that's brain
activity i'm talking about what is brain
activity do where do you think
consciousness works excuse me
consciousness is something where is your
mind it's in your brain excuse me your
empiricist yeah okay i'm telling you can
you touch consciousness
i cannot touch it no can you see it
i cannot see it no but i can experience
it and i can track it and visually
represent it
no that's not how it works it's idiotic
you cannot taste anything can you taste
it
make your case
make your case can you taste it make
your case
make your goddamn case
can you hear it no therefore it doesn't
exist
yes it is
they go yes it does
yes it does because we can hook up
because we can hook up two people
because we can hook up two people two
machines and can track their brain
activities during them having a dream
having anxiety having certain feelings
we can actually track their brain
activities we can see when it works we
can see when it stops working we can see
when it turns off when it turns on we
can track all these things due to 21st
century science and neuroscience due to
psychological research and neuroscience
something that alidawah knows nothing
can you do the same with energy for
example how much do you okay
can you do the same with with all the
energy in the in the uh that you have in
your environment can you touch it all
right can you see it all can you define
it all can you smell it all right can
you lick it and taste it all right
it's like dark matter no yeah yeah yeah
and what can you do you can put it under
a specific uh
you can put it under a specific screen
and track it you idiot that's how it
works this is science
this is science i am asking you to
demonstrate to me
i'm asking you to demonstrate to me how
consciousness has to be there in order
to bring it into existence you're an
absolute ignorance what kind of a
teacher are you studying these books
anyways engage with the actual argument
okay engage with the actual argument
come on respond to me respond to the
necessary beings
do you want to have this discussion or
not let me finish this question do you
want to have a discussion or not you
have been talking forever and cutting me
off do you will you let me talk or not
i'll cut you off everyone can see i
don't will you let me talk or not
everyone can see that you don't let me
talk to william
you asked me a question about this
you're being being personal and i'm
telling you so let me ask you a question
let me answer so
it gave rise to these dependent things
does that not require will
can you prove it can you can you show me
how that how that exactly works okay you
demonstrate okay yeah okay so there's
indeed there's dependent things
there's many dependent things in our
universe yeah the independent necessary
being has to have a will it has to will
it because they're dependent on what it
can't be infinite even amount of
dependent things they require the
necessary being to give rise to it so
the necessary being requires a will to
will it
the will has nothing to do with it being
a necessary being it is it is in no part
uh in no way part of the argument
well what is that the will
the will of the originator is in no way
part of the actual argument do you have
somebody there who can actually help
help help you with that they will say
the same thing whether that being has a
will or not has nothing to do with the
argument here at all you are talking
about something you know nothing about
open a book go to school stop driving
your taxi go to college if you want to
talk about these things educate yourself
read a book open a book learn something
about it you're talking nonsense a
whether a necessary being has a will or
a consciousness or not has nothing to do
at all with an argument from contingency
or from a necessary being that's not how
it works at all and even your dear
friends your sabor ahmed or mohammed job
i could get william lane craig here i
could ask him to review this and he will
laugh his ass off listening to your
reasoning here despite the fact that he
agrees that there is a creator you have
no clue what you're talking about you
idiot you have the iq of a bird come to
come to the actual discussion you are
talking about things you know nothing
about and embarrassing yourself while
trying to humiliate me and everybody's
seeing it people are laughing at you man
you are so embarrassing you are so damn
embarrassing on this topic you should
stop it get back to islam tell me where
the sun goes at night tell me how allah
comes to the lowest heaven at night tell
me how
how the sun and the moon chase each
other all the time tell me how the moon
will lose its light which doesn't even
have light tell me why muhammad said the
sun goes at sunset to ask for permission
to rise again and one day it will not be
given permission and go back to its uh
to its to its resting place and rise
from the west explain that to me where
does the sun go talk about relevant
things nobody cares about your idiotic
stupid understanding of theology you are
embarrassing yourself entirely
people are laughing at you i know you're
you're acting like you're completely
cool right now you're acting like you're
you have already done something right
now people are laughing at you man
people are embarrassed of you muslims
are watching and feel embarrassed with
you i have tons of messages of muslims
saying alidawah please don't embarrass
us please don't do this i can prove it i
sent you messages yesterday i sent
alidawah messages yesterday at least 15
messages 30 messages of muslims saying
brother please don't embarrass us please
don't do this you know this you know i
told you this you know i did that and
you know that you then turned off
because you were uncomfortable by that
isn't that right talk about things that
you actually claim to know something
about like islam and answer to me where
the sun goes at night come on let me
know
yeah you are come on you let it all out
you are a dumb idiot you have an iq of
90 or 85 or something i don't know okay
go ahead oh yeah i am the one who's
doing that hominix come on answer the
question where does the sun go at night
where does the sun go at night
anxiety embarrassment humiliation
uh i would say in all honesty i am
frustrated by the fact that such an
imbecile like you claims to have some
knowledge yeah recovery
acceptance is a good step to recovery
i accept that you are an imbecile yes
come on
stability instability you can't even
spell the word personal animals stop
talking about things
oh how intelligent what a great what a
great concept you don't even know how to
spell the word would you want to brag
about a word you don't even know how to
spell it anyways
you don't even know what it means which
is what you're doing right now come on
and i love that
where does the sun go
where does the sun go
that's why you're doing this i know you
i know your body where does the sun go
at night
can you start doing this hey do you know
someone named
anyways isn't it just mentioned in the
quran i've listened to you you've had
your tantrum can i speak
is mentioned in the quran what does it
mean it means
i'm not my god is yahweh
i'm talking to a fake ex-muslim he
doesn't know uh
let me talk where does the sun go at
night i'm not going to engage with your
dumb arguments any further you made
arguments i i encourage you to use this
argument go ahead where does the sun go
don't get angry yeah don't even leave
your business as soon as you talk about
something different i will cut you you
imagine you spend some time with your
family you clown you're going depressed
in your little house and you've got
keyboard
anyways i
said and let me talk okay i have where
does the sun go let me speak man i
didn't speak i know you don't talk about
irrelevant things
people on patreon are going to say bro
this guy is a liability to us
yeah sure i'm seeing that right now this
guy's the stupidest guy ever but anyway
shut the [ __ ] up where does the sun go
at night that's my question boy your
little boy where does the sun go at
night intellectually i'm an uber driver
i'm proud earning a halal living yeah
okay maybe some of your followers are
uber drivers yeah i'm an uber driver who
has an iq of a bird okay i haven't got a
degree apparently i haven't read books
but i smashed you yeah
where does the sun go at night
mohammed says the sun goes to his
resting place at night and comes back in
the morning again after asking
where does the sun go at night have a
will where does the sun go at night
what do you think would you would you
marry of your little little daughter at
the age of six
perverted prophet at the age of 55. yes
would you do that
would you do that
now
would you marry of your little daughter
at the age of six to a man who is 55
years old would you do that i'll smash
you on that would you do this
just just answer my question come on i
don't care about you necessarily you
have no clue what you're talking about
read a book about it
where does the sun go at night at least
at least i don't agree that i will have
intimacy with my own child i would i
don't i don't either i don't even at
least i don't believe i don't either
necrophilia is okay okay demonstrate to
me where where did we agree that we
would discuss your arguments today in my
own blood my own child my own family
sent your video to me when i said this
to him he wanted to vomit i said this
guy believes and i say the video of amin
you saying there is nothing wrong with
incest you said to me if there is no
harm you will have intimacy with your
own child you disgusting person i never
said that you are i never said that
i never said that